في طريق مشوار يتجه أناتولي
نحو المنزل ،
سيساعده ساشا ، وكيل السفر الذي تحول إلى متطوع ، في جمع ما بوسعه
للرحلة للحفاظ على الوقت المناسب لأكون مع
العائلة.  الابن الذي تم
تجنيده للتو ،
سيقوم الجيران الذين تم تجنيدهم برعاية دجاجاته
والماعز والكلب ،
هذا كل ما يقوله ،
دعنا نذهب يا رفاق ، سيبدأون في القصف الآن
وهو يغادر مع مجموعة من الشباب
الأوكرانيين الذين يسلمون الطعام والإمدادات
للجنود مجتمعات فرونت لاين والإجلاء
يقولون
سقطوا في كل مكان حولنا
burgberry
عام منذ عام مضى ألكساندر يدير
متجر قطع غيار السيارات وعندما
بدأت الجدران أه منذ فبراير 2022 ،
اجتمعنا معًا واستقلنا حافلة واحدة
وجمعنا بعض الأطعمة وبعض المواد
ونقوم بزياراتنا إلى
النقاط الساخنة وساخنة هذه النقاط ، فهل
يغامرون عبر القرى لا تزال
تحت النيران التي دمرتها شهور من القصف ،
جاؤوا إلى هذه القرية بحثًا عن
أشخاص سمعوا تقارير تفيد بأن 27 شخصًا ما
زالوا هنا حتى الآن على الرغم من أنهم لم
يعثروا على أي منها
أخيرًا وجدوا بابًا عليه علامات الأشخاص
الذين يختبئون في الملجأ
[موسيقى  ]
سرعان ما يذهب المتطوعون إلى العمل ولا نضيع
الوقت ،
فنحن دائمًا في الطابق السفلي
نذهب إلى هناك بمجرد أن يبدأوا في
القصف خاصة في الأيام الأخيرة ، يكون
الأمر صعبًا للغاية
ولكن تركه هنا تفضل
إبقاء والدتها في
أنا لا أخبرها دائمًا إلى أين أذهب
لأنها قلقة على حياتي كما
تقول ، لكننا نذهب على أي حال
في قرية أخرى يتم إجلاؤها
خطوة على من يعاني من قضمة الصقيع
أو لذلك يعتقد أنه لم ير طبيبًا
كنت أقوم بوضعه  مع الألم ولكن الآن أشعر بالألم
عندما أمشي ولا يمكنني الحصول على أي
علاج هنا ، يقول إنه لا يوجد
أطباء ولا مستشفى لذلك طلبت من
ابنتي وهولندا مساعدتي
الأجنبية